hey there i'm conor de languazar and
today i'm in live in ukraine with steve
kaufman also known as lingo steve on my
youtube channel
so steve and i we did uh some videos
together back
in september i think it was in vancouver
in steve's office where he's based in
canada and
we've put out this uh particular
interest in ukraine and in the ukrainian
language over the last i guess year or
so maybe a little bit longer in our case
yeah and i've been coming regularly to
ukraine of course over the last few
years what particular benefit have you
gotten from learning ukrainian in
particular how does that enhance the
trip okay like i was thinking about it
the other day and and you know you talk
about three dimension four dimension
okay so there are dimensions to travel
there's the colors the sights the
historical monuments right there's the
food there's the different uh cultural
aspects
the language is call it the fourth
dimension
if you have the language the experience
is much much more enjoyable
you understand more things first of all
i'm with my wife she can't read the
writing and if you're in a place where
there's a bunch of writing and you can't
read it it's less friendly it's it's
i've been i've been to finland for
example i can't read finnish it's less
comfortable
here i can read it it's very comfortable
and i never feel that i would be i might
be put into a situation where i won't
know what's going on yeah so it's it's
just a level of comfort it's it it makes
it much much richer
the experience i agree entirely before i
came to live to learn ukrainian of
course in ukraine i see the language
written that's a very pertinent point
and i'd always been a little bit
apprehensive about it because i don't
understand it and then it's almost a
little bit annoying because it makes me
feel uncomfortable yeah what does that
mean and just even learning the basics
of the language just made it so much
more relaxing now i read ukrainians okay
i'll probably figure it out um and it
feels a lot more familiar and in the
last few days i was in china sea uh
tennessee in the i were there was there
a beautiful town yeah also very nice
and which is near the romanian border
right and even
traveling on the train every every
everybody spoke to me ukrainian but it
was completely relaxed doesn't mean i
understood everything right but i was
able i had that level of communication
that made traveling a lot more enjoyable
less stressful one thing i want to add
too is
you had russian
so it's it's sort of easier to pick up
ukrainian
but i very much believe that you have to
put that effort into learning the
language to some level before you go to
the country because if you arrive like
cold turkey and hope that you're going
to pick up the language
it has it has been my experience that
that doesn't work you actually have to
put a fair amount of effort i had the
experience in vietnam i spent some
effort put some effort into learning
vietnamese i was there for a week all i
could ever say was thank you like
actually you need to do a fair amount of
work before you get to the country in
order
that you can take advantage of being
there and and then use as that as an
opportunity to catapult your language up
to a new level i agree entirely there's
definitely a preparatory phrase phase
before you arrive in the country where
you need to be able to play out the most
common scenarios get the basic
vocabulary down and that's just gonna
then as you say catapult is a nice word
to use to describe how it will
accelerate your your learning experience
and also what the value you get of the
trips showing up here i mean it's a lot
of discussion about language immersion
and i remember when i was younger for
example my parents sent me to
france to be immersed in the language um
well i didn't speak any french when i
arrived so it was pretty difficult it
was like a huge culture shock i didn't
understand anything even dealing with
normal everyday situations were just too
were overwhelming so coming prepared
just even just a basic amount that it
allows you to then enjoy the trip more
and to accelerate your language is vital
absolutely and and uh i mean my own
approach is to go well beyond just a few
phrases like i'll put a lot of effort
into building up my vocabulary but i
also wanted to say as much as i like
ukraine and i've i love it it's a great
uh country very interesting there are
lots of countries in the world
lots of cultures in the world and and
and we have this opportunity today with
with travel with the internet we have
this opportunity to go and stop discover
lots of different languages and cultures
and wherever you do go i think this
fourth dimension the language just
enhances
the you know the just the enjoyment that
you can get from the trip so it needn't
be ukrainian it can be swahili it can be
gaelic in ireland i don't know whatever
well that's not going to give you too
much
to be honest that's going to be just a
couple of regions but it will definitely
transform your experience there of
course if you're a canadian you show up
you can speak irish i mean even
impresses me and it's on my perspective
if you have no irish roots on top of it
for sure so
this preparatory phase is i think vital
for getting the most out of your your
travel experiences and actually that's
why i design a free training course uh
people people have to be on my my
mailing list there's a link below it's
completely free
and uh you'll then receive my free
training course where i give you this
kind of guide where i will present this
guidance and the preparatory steps that
you need to get the most out of
uh learning a language uh for traveling
and then doing this preparatory stage
and showing up
with the right mindset and language
skills to survive i would like to ask
you because we've known each other for
quite a while and i know that you travel
and your passion is languages and
helping people learn languages
so let me ask you just what exactly is
this preparatory course talk a bit about
it so
what i've been working on is a by
step-by-step guide learn the basics of
the language that will help you
not to avoid being lost on your trip i'm
frustrated uh stressed when you arrive
and then when you're on the trip you'll
be able to then accelerate that language
learning and get the most out of it in
terms of
of being in the country because a lot of
complaints that people make is that they
show up and then the locals maybe reply
to them in english maybe they're in a
tourist space all that that's just one
part of it what's even more i think
valuable
in this course in in this course will be
how to
how the travel experience as close to
being a local as possible right so
language is one element you talk about a
fourth dimension but also it's being
able to find the best places it's like
avoiding being scammed staying safe um
you know making friends making contacts
with people really understanding the
culture getting the most out of it i
mean no one really
enjoys well definitely no one enjoys
being ripped off right now something
happens a lot to tourists i think people
who are uh who are informed travelers
and try to get in touch with local
culture they get it saves them a lot of
money first of all because they get
cheaper prices that's just like and i
know that you've been very successful at
doing that in some strange countries i
shouldn't say strange but countries that
have traveled through less often like
ukraine
brazil and other places belarus uh but
what so i think you're a very good
source of information because it comes
from your own personal experience but
what format is this going to take is
this a series of videos is it books uh
audio cds what exactly is it gonna be
it's gonna be a video series i mean it
will have some exercises to help
reinforce the training um at the end of
each uh each module and it will have to
be accompanied by text but primarily
it's a video training course right and
it will take you yeah through all the
steps to be able to you know travel
learn the languages beforehand in
preparation get the most out of your
experience while you're there and that
this it's really nice to be phrased as a
fourth dimension right by the way steve
is wearing uh bishop anchor yeah i
should explain what this is right well
today
unfortunately got some competition here
but today is constitution day in ukraine
which is the celebration of their now i
understand that the first ukrainian
constitution was written in 1704
or something
uh so people are celebrating so i
figured i would wear my ukrainian shirt
so steve it's been cool to hang out
again in other countries yeah
we'll have to do this again somewhere
else
everybody
goodbye
from live in ukraine
[Music]